Hi.
Andy Granowitz here, developer
advocate for Google Analytics.
Today, I'm going to talk a
little about Google Analytics
and why you might
want to use it.
Google Analytics is a tool
to collect and analyze
data on user interactions
with your business.
It exists to help you improve
and optimize those interactions
and your business as a whole.
It's free to use and is
very popular for mobile apps
and websites, but
you can measure
important actions your
users take offline
in Google Analytics as well.
Whatever the task, many
people in any organization
will find using Google Analytics
valuable-- for example,
marketers.
Marketers use it to optimize
campaigns and determine
the most effective
marketing channels.
Designers use Google
Analytics to understand
how users are interacting with
their website or app as well
as the impact on
interface design changes
that they may make.
Front end developers take
advantage of the ability
to measure page load times,
broken links or 404 pages,
JavaScript errors, and so on.
For these reasons,
I highly recommend
giving everyone in your
organization access
to Google Analytics, so
they're empowered to dig deep
into the data on their own.
This is a big advantage over
siloed data analytics systems
that only a few people
have access to or know
how to use or only
produce static reports
on a periodic basis.
All of your Google
Analytics data
can be accessed at any
time, and the interface
is really great for ad hoc
analysis, impromptu analysis,
things like that.
I should note, if you do have
sensitive data like sales
or marketing spend that
you may not want everyone
in your organization to
see, you can restrict access
to certain parts
of Google Analytics
while still having the benefit
of giving many people access
to the data that they need.
It's important to spend some
time thinking through what
your primary objectives
are as a business
and think about how
this trickles down
to your analytics.
For example, if your goal is
customer acquisition or getting
people to sign up
for your service,
this will translate
into specific metrics
that you can optimize for.
One such metric is, of
course, total user sign ups.
But you might also want to
consider user trials, repeated
visits to informational pages,
the number of email newsletter
sign ups, and so on.
These data points will be
important to understand
and measure the effectiveness
of different activities
and changes that you make.
You can do this type of
analysis in Google Analytics.
See the impact of a
change that you've
made on the metrics
that indicate success.
So take some time
and think about,
what are your high level
business objectives?
What are the objectives
of your website, app,
or any other digital properties
you operate, and then
specific measurable goals
for these digital properties
that you're trying to optimize?
In fact, you can tell Google
Analytics what your goals are,
and then it will help you
optimize for these goals.
In Google Analytics when
someone completes a goal,
it's called a goal conversion.
Watch the next
video to learn more
about some of the
important things
to consider when setting up
Google Analytics for the very
first time.